in the US eight out of ten coronavirus
related deaths involve seniors people
who are at least 65 years old also
account for more than half of the ICU
hospitalizations Errol Barnett spoke
with volunteers who are coming together
to help the most vulnerable and most in
need I have been matched up with a
matching program to help me with my
needs until recently you Lee Moore and
Mason Bremer were perfect strangers Lee
who is 74 year old sweet sweet woman now
they meet almost every day
she needs grocery runs she has some
Pharmacy mean she's got fibromyalgia the
duo found each other through AK Ovid 19
relief program in Louisville Kentucky it
pairs those who are medically at risk
with those who are not what would you be
doing today if you didn't have Mason
helping you that's a good question I
guess I would have to find something I'm
not sure what I'm just very very lucky
to have 26 year old Braemar provides
support to more by running basic errands
and also offering invaluable company
even if it's on the phone what are your
biggest concerns right now early my
concern is really for the whole world
I'm hoping that we can find you and take
care of one who needed the most
coast-to-coast Americans are mobilizing
to help our most vulnerable being able
to help their neighbor is one of the
most American things that you can do to
limit the chance of exposure to her
elderly neighbors Becky Hoffler in North
Carolina takes care of their daily
grocery needs utilizing people power I
think is one of the best ways that we
can combat the virus there's also this
North Texas Facebook group with nearly
8,000 members drawing on the strings of
everyone a virtual community working on
real ways to help seniors in more ways
than one we're in such a dire need
strengthening everyone's immunity and
this is a great way to do that and what
has surprised you about what they are
asking us
take five of this take 10 of money they
say no I don't want more because I want
to do some for me thanks Wow under the
current national emergency guidelines
visitors have restricted access to
nursing homes so from Florida to Arizona
they're using technology as a workaround
and in New York City City Meals on
Wheels is prepping over a quarter of a
million meals per week for homebound
seniors roughly half the amount they
serve in an entire year people are
beginning to realize that they can help
they're not working their home and so
they come out in droves to help us
volunteers making a difference with a
simple donation of time and as for more
and breeam up the difference is one they
hope lasts a lifetime what type of
friendship are you guys developing do
you think it will outlast the pandemic
yes I sure hope so how great is that and
more than just an uber driver for CBS
this morning
Errol Barnett New York bonded for life
nice work Mason good name to the great
program matching people like that
because a lot of places depend on
volunteers and they don't have them
right now because people are home that's
right